un Magnate de los negocios un general
retirado del ejército y una economista
Quien será el próximo presidente checo
andrey pavish tiene un patrimonio neto
estimado de cuatro millones de dólares
absuelto esta misma semana de cargos de
fraude en la subvenciones el ex Primer
Ministro aseguró que las acusaciones
tenían motivaciones políticas
creo que todos estos escándalos han sido
organizados por gente que no quiere que
yo esté en política porque he creado
movimiento contra la corrupción porque
soy completamente independiente y nadie
puede corromperme
también en la carrera el general Pavel
paracaidista condecorado de la guerra
servo croata que luego hizo carrera en
la otan el candidato independiente se ha
distanciado Víctor Urban y de Los Socios
del grupo de segregado y es firmemente
proeuropeo
Espero que República Checa forme parte
firmemente de una comunidad de Naciones
democráticas representadas entre otros
por la Unión Europea y nos beneficia
formar parte de tal agrupación
Y por último con solo 44 años la
profesora de anula nerudoba una
economista su campaña se ha dirigido a
los jóvenes por las redes sociales y se
ha centrado en cuestiones sociales como
el coste de la vida y la igualdad de
género
soy la representante del futuro he
vivido en libertad casi toda mi vida y
me gustaría convertirme en la presidenta
de la nueva generación
el papel del presidente en República
Checa sobre todo ceremonial de hecho el
titular saliente se ha enfrentado a
críticas por su injerencia en la
política interior y exterior no obstante
los presidentes tienen voz y voto a
través de los nombramientos de primeros
ministros y son comandantes en jefe de
las fuerzas armadas